>> IF YOU ARE SMUGGLING A CHILD
THEN WE WILL PROSECUTE YOU.
AND THAT CHILD MAY BE SEPARATED
FROM YOU AS REQUIRED BY LAW.
WE DON’T WANT TO SEPARATE
FAMILIES, BUT WE DON’T WANT
FAMILIES TO COME TO THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
>> EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THIS COUNTRY SEPARATES
PARENTS AND CHILDREN WHEN THEY
ARE ARRESTED FOR A CRIME.
THIS IS NO NEW POLICY.
>> THERE IS NO BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR CHANGING THAT.
>> IMMIGRATION SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
1500 OF THEM, THE HEADLINE SAID
HAD BEEN LOST UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION’S ADHERENCE TO
THIS POLICY.
HHS PUT OUT A STATEMENT REFUTING
THAT, SAYING THE ASSERTION THAT
UNACCOMPANIED ALIEN CHILDREN ARE
LOST IS COMPLETELY FALSE.
THESE CHILDREN ARE NOT LOST,
THEIR SPONSORS ARE USUALLY
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THEY HAVE
BEEN VETTED IN CRIMINALITY AND
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR THEM
AND COULD NOT BE REACHED BY THE
VOLUNTARY WOULD CALL WAS MADE.
IN MANY CASES SPONSORS CANNOT BE
REACHED BECAUSE THEY THEMSELVES
ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS AND DO NOT
WANT TO BE REACHED BY FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES.
SO, WHAT ABOUT THIS ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY ON WHERE
IMMIGRATION STANDS CURRENTLY, SO
LET’S BRING IN THE PANEL.
AND IT STEVE HAYES, EDITOR AND
CHIEF AND MATT SCHLAPP,
CONTRIBUTOR WITH THE HILL.
MARA, THIS GOT LOTS OF
ATTENTION.
>> IT HAS A LOT OF ATTENTION AND
HAS A LOT OF PARTS TO IT.
ON ONE HAND, THESE CHILDREN
BEING LOST IS NOT TRUE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, AS YOU JUST
HEARD THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
MADE VERY CLEAR IT WANTED TO
CONTINUE THAT BECAUSE IT’S A
DETERRENT.
DON’T BRING YOUR KIDS HERE
ILLEGALLY BECAUSE YOU WILL GET
SEPARATED FROM THEM.
THEY DECIDED THEY WANTED TO
BLAME IT ON DEMOCRATS EVEN
THOUGH THAT WAS A POLICY THAT
THEY CARRY THROUGH.
>> Bret: BUT, STEVE, THE
CHARACTERIZATION OF IT THEY
DEPEND ON WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING
OR READING.
OR, THE POLICY WENT BACK A
COUPLE OF ADMINISTRATIONS.
>> IF THAT’S TRUE BUT THIS
REALLY TOOK OFF OVER THE WEEKEND
WHEN YOU HAD A FORMER OBAMA
SPEECHWRITER JON FAVREAU AND
OTHERS PUTTING THIS OUT THERE,
PUTTING UP PICTURES OF CHILDREN
IN CAGES AND IT WAS OUTRAGEOUS.
BECAUSE IT WAS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DOING THIS,
FAILING TO NOTE THAT THIS HAD
HAPPENED AS YOU SAY UNDER
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
SO THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK
THAT POURED FUEL ON THIS
PROVERBIAL FIRE, IF YOU WILL.
THERE’S NO QUESTION THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING
TO TAKE A TOUGH STAND ON ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS WHICH ARE UP
AFTER INITIALLY GOING DOWN AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BY SAYING THIS,
AND MAKING THIS PART OF THEIR
POLICY.
WE SAW WITH THE POWER OF
PRESIDENTIAL RHETORIC AND THE
POWER OF ADMINISTRATION RHETORIC
DID TO DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
I THINK THAT IS THEIR GOAL HERE
AND WE COULD DEBATE WHETHER THIS
IS THE RIGHT POLICY OR NOT.
THEY HAVE SAID, BOTH JOHN KELLY
AND CHIEF OF STAFF WHO JUST
PLAYED, THEY MADE CLEAR THAT
THEY VIEW THIS AS AN EFFECTIVE
DETERRENT.
>> Bret: I ALWAYS SAY THE
DISCLAIMER OR I TRY TO COME UP
YOUR WIFE WORKS FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE THOUGHT
PROCESS IS, BEHIND OF THIS MOVE?
ARE THEY PUSHING BACK BEHIND THE
BAD NEWS STORIES ON THIS OR IS
THAT A STRATEGY HERE THAT’S
DEVELOPING ON THE IMMIGRATION?
>> BRETT, BE CAREFUL GETTING
INTO THE MIND OF YOUR SPOUSE.
THE ONLY THING THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
DIFFERENTLY THAN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT COMES TO
PEOPLE WITH UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS, IT’S A CRIMINAL
VIOLATION ONE IT COMES TO ADULTS
TRYING TO CROSS OUR BORDERS
ILLEGALLY.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH THE KIDS?
WHAT HERE ARE THE IS THE KICKER.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM WILL STAY IN
AMERICA FOR AS LONG AS THEY WAN
WANT.
LET’S -- WE ALWAYS SEND HOME --
WE ONLY SENT HOME SOMETHING LIKE
FIVE KIDS LAST YEAR.
IF AN UNACCOMPANIED MINOR GETS
TO OUR BORDER, THEY STAY IN
AMERICA.
AND MOST OF THEM, OR GIVING,
GIVEN A PLACE TO SAY, THEY ARE
GIVEN TO RELATIVES WHO ARE
THEMSELVES HERE ILLEGALLY.
SO WHEN DEMOCRATS SAY THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION LOST 1500
KIDS, MARA’S RIGHT, THAT’S NOT
ACCURATE.
WE’VE ACTUALLY LOST 20 MILLION
PEOPLE AND OF THOSE 20 MILLION
PEOPLE ARE BRINGING IN MORE
RELATIVES TO THE BORDER.
THAT’S WHY WHETHER YOU BUILD A
WALL OR NOT, WE HAVE PROBLEMS OF
THE BORDER THAT THERE ARE ALL
THESE LOOPHOLES THAT ALLOW YOU
TO HOPSCOTCH IN LINE TO BE IN
AMERICA IF YOU WANT TO BE.
>> Bret: THE KEY POINT HERE IS
THE REASON THE LAW STORY IS NOT
ACCURATE IS BECAUSE THEY WERE
CALLING THESE.
AND THEY DIDN’T RETURN A, JOHN
KELLY, JEFF SESSIONS SAYING, WE
ARE GOING TO SEPARATE THESE KIDS
AS A LAW SAYS WE SHOULD, SO
DON’T BRING THEM.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT SOUNDS LIKE
THEY FEEL THAT THEY WANT TO
BLAME THAT SEPARATION ON
DEMOCRATS.
>> Bret: BUT DO YOU THINK THIS
IS A POLITICAL ISSUE, ONE THAT’S
POWERFUL FOR THE DEMOCRATS?
>> WE WANT TO SAY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS HEARTLESS.
BUT WHAT IS SO INTERESTING TO ME
IS THAT DONALD TRUMP DOES HAVE A
SOUP TOP SPOT IN THE IMMIGRATION
DEBATE.
THE DACA KIDS, HE OFTEN SAYS HE
LOVES THEM AND WANTS TO TREAT
THEM WITH A GREAT HEART.
HE CLEARLY DOESN’T WANT TO BE ON
THE WRONG SIDE OF THE STORY.
>> Bret: AND STEVE, LAST WORD.
THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE AS WE HEAD
TOWARD THE MIDTERMS?
>> THAT’S EASY.
I CAN EASILY PREDICT WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
ACTUALLY NOBODY KNOWS.
THE SHORT TERM, THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE AND
THERE IS NOT CONSENSUS ON HOW
THEY SHOULD PROCEED IN THE
HOUSE.
WE HAVE MORE RESTRICTION EFFORTS
LIKE THE GOOD LEGISLATION THAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN PUSHING
FOR A LONG TIME.
AND, THE LONGER TERM IS, HOW